the no damage absolutely be adding
danichiro left and right that was
beautiful chat
hello uh my name is mitraz i am a securo
speedrunner i recently performed a
blindfolded speedrun of securo at
agdq2022 and i'm gonna break down some
of the iconic moments and boss fights
from that so let's check it out
to get to blindfolded it basically came
down to i started doing challenge runs
and then i i wanted to do new challenges
but it was like man everyone's done
everything already and i just wanted
something new i wanted something nobody
had done before that i knew i could do
and since i'd seen all the bosses
individually done blindfolded i said i
know i can route that out and get a full
blindfolded playthrough
good luck mitch i believe in you
my name
[Music]
i have a specific way that i'm gonna
start the fight
that lets me get attacks in firecrackers
which actually does a lot of posture and
lets me get more free attacks in um and
then immediately gets him into
uh a stagger right after
and so that it almost takes out his
entire phase one just by itself and then
we just have to do phase two
the akko here totally unnecessary
um it just makes the second phase a
little bit faster it is a speed run
after all but
um
that's the only reason for that
so five slashes at the start
then firecrackers seven slashes
unfortunately i lost the lock on here
that's super rare that almost never
happens
the way i actually got the lock on back
is i i basically was just swinging my
camera around and pressing the grapple
button
once i heard that i got the grapple i
knew i was faced at him so i locked back
on
from here i have to fight him kind of
normally so i can hear him grunting
for each of his attacks
and so then i know ah this is the three
hit this is
the big swing this is
you know this one
i don't have a name for all of them but
in my head i can keep them straight
lost the lock on again
so obviously there's only a set number
of attack animations that an enemy has
um
and some of them are multi-hit so he'll
do three hits in a row exactly one two
three
every time that he starts that first
attack he'll do the second and third so
that would be
kind of what i might call an attack
pattern um gobu doesn't have a lot of
extended attack patterns like this into
this into this he's more so just one
into the next into the next
in this case it was easier to fight him
than it would be to get him to run off
the cliff just because that jump it's
not that hard to um set up if i if i
could definitely get to the tower
but running across an entire open field
with no walls to orient myself or slide
along um
with gobu yelling in my ear so i can't
hear how many sprints i'm doing so i
can't hear if i've gotten things it just
made it a little bit too too tough of a
task to try to get that particular skip
i can keep track better of the lines in
english than in any other language and
because i i am relying on hearing
when
voice lines start when they stop for
audio cues uh it's just easier for me to
keep track of those in english um it
works fine in japanese i think i've
actually done it in japanese before the
only thing is sometimes i'll get
confused on certain dialogue
certain dialogue lines that i'll just
confuse two of them because they sound
kind of similar whereas in english i i
can actually understand the words so i
can separate them better
now [ __ ] told me that this is maybe the
miniboss he's the most nervous form
see aggie aggie says yep i am the most
nervous for this mini boss that was
definitely true
so it starts up with movement to get in
kind of as normal and then everything
from here is a setup to get a deflect on
him
so i take these exact movements
in order to get into an exact position
right here
if this goes correctly it's going to be
very quick which is exactly five slashes
and one jump
will get me
the perfect timing to get the deflect
and
based off then five
and i get it actually here on the very
first attempt three head shots and then
firecrackers but then i attack a little
too early here so i get a body shot
instead of a head shot
and that ruins the entire thing because
he gets a couple hits on me
i don't get the hits on him and he ends
up killing me
to be honest i was thinking
i knew this would happen i i had
mentally prepared myself for this for
weeks because i knew bull was going to
be the one that was going to give me
trouble that if i can make it through
bull
the rest of the run shouldn't be too big
of a deal
um
there's obviously a few other difficult
parts but bull was the part that i was i
was just really nervous for but also
prepared for it to go poorly because it
it does a lot of the time
so
uh that that was mostly my thoughts uh
and then i i just took the time i think
you can even see in my camera between
runs
i breathe i
i just center myself before giving it
another go
even
um glitch in glitchless you fight him
instead of skipping him and he is the
the just the bane of my existence in in
that run um so weird with his movement
so weird with
the deflect timing on him feels weird it
it's just everything about him
just ah
annoys me but especially in blindfolded
i have no idea how to how to properly
kill him
without without possibly taking a death
i've got a setup for the start and after
that i'm kind of just praying
yeah finally getting through the the
toughest boss
okay he gets the industry all right so
that's the the perfect start three hits
firecrackers wait for him to come back
down
one two three four he did hit me a bit
but i did get the fifth hit off
not ideal but good enough and from this
point he's just kind of
playing oh i got burned i didn't even
it
know
the bowl has very bad audio cues because
he's just running around like yeah so
now i'm on a time limit before i'm just
gonna die
ah this is horrible luck he is just
running around
kind of just perry spamming hoping he
gets the hit there
oh my god again he won't stop
there we go
well okay and the first step i think he
might revive to go for this again
yeah if he just keeps running around
there's pretty much nothing i can do
about it because it's not like i can see
where he is to follow him
so i just have to hope that at some
point he's going to stop running
it just it just goes well enough so
actually i got very lucky at the end um
when you get him low on health
or technically high on posture
he has a chance to just
freak out and run into a wall and
luckily that happened if it didn't
happen it was going to be a real tight
race to the finish there of whether i
died or he died first
this
will only take a moment
before i fought ganitro i was an
absolute noob at the game just kind of
struggling my way through blocking
mostly
didn't really get the deflect system
didn't know how to mikiri counter didn't
know how to jump over sweeps
after gennichiro i was a master
i still got my butt kicked by every boss
after but i felt i felt like i improved
so much just in that one fight i think
kenichiro to me was kind of like the
teaching fight it was the all right all
right you've had a little chance to play
around now
now get good
genny's a little bit weird there's a
little distance between us so if i just
kept attacking like i did on lone shadow
some of the attacks would actually miss
they come from the wrong side of your
body and they don't hit far enough to
the left
so to make sure i do hit him to my left
i'm blocking and then starting up a
first attack again because the first
attack always works so then i just reset
my combo by blocking
but i do know that it is 21 hits
of the um reset
but i always go for 22 just in case
because i'm not taking that chance
and then from here
if you use any healing item
including persimmon which doesn't
actually heal but counts as a healing
item he will always go for a thrust to
try to interrupt your heel that gives
you a free mikiri counter on his thrust
every single time
that gets his posture almost full and
then from there i just use firecrackers
to finish him off
as soon as you know one thing that they
are guaranteed to do just find the way
to punish that one thing and get them to
do it and that's that's pretty much an
easy way to make a a speed run or
blindfolded speedrun strategy
and if we could just get like one more
healing item i wouldn't even need to use
the firecrackers i think
that's definitely one of my favorites
where uh the other blindfolded runners
pretty much actually fight him and i
just said i don't want to actually fight
him that sounds hard
i want to just cheese him so uh start to
finish just don't let him do anything
[Music]
and then uh for guardian ape yeah phase
one this is just a pure speed run
strategy
uh if you
he's supposed to stagger take a few hits
and then on the final hit he runs away
but if you just don't do the final hit
he doesn't run away and it actually
doesn't reset his stagger bar at all so
he's still at full stagger um he's no
longer in the stagger animation so when
you hit him it just starts the loop all
over again
very speedy
and very easy for blindfolded
you just have to hear him getting up it
is a little hard to hear um because he
is very noisy but pretty manageable
he gets back up you're telling me
there's a phase two what uh but yeah and
then for phase two uh it's pretty much i
just throw everything and the kitchen
sink at him of i use every single item
available
i use jumping mortal draw which is the
most powerful uh skill in the game to
get a bunch of damage on him
and then basically i'm just trying to
stagger him as much as possible using
those jumping mortal draws so i use a
jumping mortal draw to stagger him
use a second jumping mortal draw to get
him close to stagger
and then the very next hit will get him
right back into another stagger right
there
waiting through the combo oh my gosh
so basically i barely have to
actually interact with his attacks
because for most of the fight he ends up
being staggered
if you had to fight both of them if you
couldn't just kill the main one and then
move on
yeah that would be tough i don't know if
i could do that blindfolded but when you
can just kill the main one in about you
know 10 seconds and then get out of
there
it's not too bad
for double ape
it's super hard casually but in a speed
run it's actually like by far the
easiest boss because he just doesn't
have a lot of health
and so if you save him for late in the
game when you have a lot of attack power
you can see a single mortal draw
basically just did half his health
just two mortal draws
and a couple hits and he's down
it seems
we have a
troubling guest
so for emma we uh pick up the double
ichimonji skill
um this was actually originally thought
of by lil aggie the commentator
um but he would dodge afterwards
which worked for most of emma's attacks
but not this one in particular the three
hit you would dodge the first and then
she'd just smack you second and third
and kill you so i figured out that by
blocking instead
it actually always works
usually the downside to blocking is you
gain posture but double each emoji
actually recovers your posture it's part
of the skill that it recovers your
posture so it doesn't matter that you're
blocking her attacks
then
we switch over to mortal draw which does
more damage um but it's a similar thing
of we just use mortal draw and then
we're gonna get out of the way of his
next attack
in this case we do mortal draw
then two hits miss those unfortunately
then dodge out of the way of his next
attack and just loop from there
same thing on the final phase i'm out of
emblem so it'll take a bit longer it'll
take like four or five mortal draws
instead of two or three
but uh overall same strategy
mortal draw two hits dodge
and jump
and we see okay there's a second md he
probably needs two more for finishing
this off
it looks to be a pretty good position it
depends which way easton dodges here he
might get stuck on that wall
oh he squeezes his body he's gonna do it
that is it
the no damage when's the time coming up
time will be as soon as the game logo
appears after it fades to black so
there's about 10 seconds
that fight sometimes takes
four or five tries just to
not have something go wrong um
especially
aggie was even mentioning in the
commentary
walls are the biggest enemy because if
there's a wall and you try to dodge you
just still get hit because you didn't
actually get out of the way um
so really really happy that that worked
first try um it does work most of the
time probably
70 of the time but
you know when uh 30 of the time means
you just have to do it over and over
again that's not great
now time
[Music]
unbelievable absolutely
unbelievable what was the was that like
just over two hours oh my god
well my my immediate thing was my my
parents actually had come over to watch
it live in the other room on the big
screen tv
so uh i i turned off stream i said i'll
see you you all later you online people
and i went and i i sort of celebrated
with my parents
they brought me some food from a food
truck uh and and we just we just had a
little little party little celebration
um before i i came back and checked
everything online
the the routing was probably 90 just me
by myself trying things and then the the
help that i had was generally through
twitch chat in between oh i try this it
didn't work take off the blindfold look
over at chat and they suggest do this
try this and giving me ideas for how to
fix it up there are definitely a few
strategies that other people came up
with
for example the tutorial was almost
entirely a runner that had started the
blindfolded project way before me
just had no plans to actually finish it
soon they were just kind of like slowly
working on making a route and then some
of the other strategies was from a
particularly uh wonderful person in my
chat called zelich who just
anytime that i had some place that i was
really stuck on i couldn't find
something they're like hold on let me
try that
i'll come back in an hour with a
strategy you move on and do the next
thing and i was like wow thank you so
much when i finally did it it it was
definitely the greatest achievement i've
done getting world records is one thing
getting the world's first is entirely
different that was so cool that was like
just the greatest experience i've had
with uh with completing any run at all i
don't think that you need the greatest
memory ever for a lot of this stuff
because it is so
um
chunked out into little pieces
and
it's
i i think it does have to do with i am
very familiar with the game
so i'll always know you know oh i'm in
this spot so i need to do this thing or
the menuing for the menuing the
items are always in the exact same order
all right uh shout outs to uh my
wonderful twitch community at twitch.tv
slash mitriz i stream a few times a week
if you want to check me out there shout
out to the securo speedrunning community
they are so awesome and so helpful and i
don't think i could have done this
blindfolded run without their help
always willing to help out find new
strategies and routing and everything
together and if you are at all
interested please check it out um but
try it with your eyes open first it'll
be a lot easier i promise
chat i want all the five dollar
donations to come in if he gets this
first try
yeah this is a big one
locking on dropping down oh my gosh
legend frame perfect now gonna go for
the sub pixel perfect sub frame perfect
all the sword swaps the left the right
he's out of there first try miss noble
in the bag